so how are you i i'm good i appreciate
you talking about this i thought it was
just it's such a
especially for
you know someone like me that loves
movies it's so fun to watch something
like this i'm surprised that there
hasn't been a movie like this before
i know it's true other than cinema
paradiso there's no movie about a less
picture show but there's no movie about
going to the movies and that's what i
always wanted to do so it's been so
weird to bring that up because i've had
you the script for a while the idea for
like 15 years i was terrified that
someone was going to do it that was like
that was the terror i had over the years
like someone's going to do something
similar because like you
i thought there was a movie to be mined
about cinema
inspiration the magic of the theater
experience so interesting you said that
when did you make the leap from you know
having the idea of actually sitting down
to write it
god i think it was i think it was after
purge two i think i think i felt oh i
was happy with where purge two came out
i had the idea
and everything felt kind of right there
i was like oh maybe i can maybe the
financing will cut i know it's it's much
harder to get financing for
a small personal film than something
like purge which is a you know genre
movie so i felt like oh maybe the the
success of the purges will help me find
the financing for this is the night
which was back then called the night
rocky iii opened and then it began once
upon a time in staten island and then
this is the night so it says it's title
changes but yeah i think it was after
purge too where i sat down and wrote it
and uh and then showed sebastian and
jason and
luckily they liked it and here we are
i love that you've done enough purge
movies and you've done them for long
enough that you can just judge them by
which purge movie you did and you know
tell me like oh i did this after this
purge because right exactly yeah this
happened
it's been it's been like
i think it's only been nine years of the
purges so i remember like every break i
had in between them i'm like okay i
wrote a book at one point two books
actually in the time period
several scripts but this was the big
thing that i wanted to get done during
this kind of per the purge decade of my
life
your love of cinema is obvious was it
always rocky 3 that you wanted to base
this around did you ever consider any
other films did it always have to be
this one
it was from the seat it was always rocky
3 which i think rocky iii
i i always attributed it to be being
that this was in such an italian
american neighborhood it really the
rocky character was so beloved here but
i think the mythology of rocky had built
up just this crescendo by rocky iii that
it really was this event everybody was
going we waited three three and a half
hours online we saw it twice in two days
it inspired everything from people
wanting to do good things to guys
fighting over seats it was really this
event that the whole kids were holding
the poster in school it was really crazy
and i think it was because of one and
two or so below but then i spoke to
people from other parts of the country
and it was equally as an event i think
and that's what so i was wrong it wasn't
just the italian-american nature there
was something i think about the rocky
character that people found you know he
was beloved across across ethnicities
and uh but the only time we considered
another film was so i never did in the
writing stage or the seat of the idea
i always wanted well two things i always
wanted the movie at some point
as you can see in the movie i don't show
scenes from rocky iii during the
screening i purposefully didn't show
rocky 3 because at some point i wanted
to be
more of a
a metaphor for any movie that you could
be watching so i was like oh i don't
want to show and then i got a lot of
notes saying no no you should show rocky
3. let's show more even stallone said
james show some scenes rocky iii and
then we tried the edit to do that and it
changed the whole nature of the sequence
it became about
watching rocky three you get caught up
in rocky three which was bad it's like
no no there's another movie playing so
don't watch rocky iii but it also took
the it i wanted to be about the
emotional experience of the audience and
it changed that so
but then it's some so that was one thing
but
at some point there was a rights issue
that we confronted someone was afraid
that we weren't going to get the rights
to show the imagery from rocky iii i
think from ua or mgua mgm and uh they
said james it's a good script can you
substitute another movie that would
create such a event
and create this night of inspiration and
courage and i was hard-pressed to find
anything i said i wanted to i did i was
very saddened by this that we couldn't
get the rights at the time luckily we
did and everybody was so cool at uam gm
they read the script and they were very
happy to give us the rights uh to use
rocky's imagery so i thought what about
it somebody said karate kid i'm like no
that's doesn't work godfather was a bit
the godfather was a very big thing here
in staten island
but it didn't feel right that people
would be inspired by the godfathers i
don't think people cheer during the
godfather films they're an event but
people aren't cheering so so yeah it
never long answer no not really did we
ever consider anything else
i i love to just the fun of watching
them all waiting in line and having to
actually buy the tickets in person
because yeah i know i used to do that a
lot concert tickets but it's just that
alone is such a rare thing oh well
that's what you know
ultimately what i'm trying to talk to my
love of film my love of movies and but
also about the theatrical experience and
i like that you bring waiting in line
because i think that's part of what
makes it so special is we wait we're
anticipating something we're driving
somewhere we're getting canned food
where there's a long line sometimes i
think losing all that
you just can't reply you can't replicate
it at home and that's what makes me so
sad moving into the future as we see the
theater experience we're being told
might go away eventually which terrifies
me so i hope this is not an artifact
from a time that's forgotten i hope that
somehow i think people will return to
the cinemas i have hope that things will
return to a good you know uh
time where people wanted to sit you know
get out of their houses after covid i
think it's happening already but yeah i
was i think that's part of it driving
waiting online and i haven't done that
either we buy all our tickets online now
so we lose part of that experience which
you know i hold dear
yeah i mean it's funny because you don't
even have to try to wait for a seat that
you want anymore because seats are
assigned yeah exactly like all the
little things you're reminded of that
aren't part of the experience anymore
exactly it's uh yeah no one finds
overseas anymore we used to fight people
especially rocky movies people are
punching each other to get good seats no
it's true all those little things even i
tried to do something where even
spoilers i think are much different now
how we deal with spoilers so in the
beginning of the movie the boys are
talking about is someone going to die in
the film maybe there was a rumor so now
we'd probably be able to we probably
heard who's going to die going into it
yeah we can read about it now back then
it was much more mysterious you know we
heard this rumor is it true so i think
there's less mystery too because of so
much information out there that we can
have access to so everything's changed
but uh i hope that the experience
doesn't change that much i hope that the
theater is always there because again
it's never as immersive anywhere else
this movie is very different from the
purge franchise obviously
and most people would probably be
shocked to learn it's the same
person that you know created both of
these things
did you write this at a time when you
needed something different for yourself
i mean were you looking for something
just to really even just cleanse the
palate of yes purge
yes i always say this is me purging the
purge like this is my way and then i
went back and purged after this again
but i always i also call the movies
oddly i always say it's the good field
purge because the purge inspires people
to do very bad things the most dastardly
things in the world aren't murdering
someone whereas i think rocky and movies
i'm saying inspire people to be
better versions of themselves so it's my
anti-purge film it's go out and be
courageous and fight your fears in a
good way so no absolutely absolutely i
think i needed something that uh i love
every kind of film i know there's
certain i guess filmmakers who
are set into making just one genre uh
but i'd love to i'd love to cross genres
i like the cross genres in the same film
which a lot of people yell at me for and
i know they don't like so as you can see
there's many tonal there's tonal changes
in this film all over the place which i
love but i know it's it's a personal
thing that i know other people don't but
yeah i love
it was a way to definitely do something
different i hope i can continue to do
different things that would be wonderful
yeah i mean i've always kind of been in
the mindset where you know genre doesn't
matter if it's a really great story and
great characters and the actors do a
great job with the material
yeah it's why i always find it so weird
when people are like oh i hate horror oh
i hate comedy or it's like you just
haven't seen one that you identify with
absolutely yeah just find a good one
you'll love it exactly
everything you think about that genre
and uh yeah so that's a and i love i
love movies that mix up genres it's hard
to find but you see a lot of european
cinema japanese cinema too but uh i
tried to do that to that here where it's
you know we got absurdity we got comedy
we got melodrama we got hard drama so
yeah i love it i love all the different
genres
it's so interesting too looking at your
movies because this does feel like a
film that's closer to the first film you
did then obviously to the purge films
yes did it feel at all like a return to
your roots as a filmmaker
does it feel like this might have been
the next movie you had made if you
hadn't done the purge
absolutely yeah i think that's what's so
weird when people i'm so happy you
you're even aware of my first film uh
staten island new york with ethan hawk
and vincent d'annaprio uh because i
always say who wouldn't be aware of that
teamwork
that's right exactly it's a great team
up uh
they are amazing i always wanted to
write a tv show for the two of them
because they're wonderful people too but
yeah i think that movie and and rocky
iii or the night three open door this is
tonight are directly correlated in a way
uh or connected i should say whereas the
purge then pops out in between so people
say oh this doesn't seem like you're
like oh you probably haven't seen my
first film so i'm so happy you saw it
you know it's uh
it's uh i find it a very interesting
film so yeah i felt like i was
it was nice to know i could do it again
meaning that because you worry as a
filmmaker that am i going to get locked
in and i'm only going to people are only
going to want x from me from now on it's
a terror you know i'm privileged to make
films and i'd continue making horror
thriller dystopian action films whatever
the purge is considered but i you want
to try different things so
it was very nice to be able to return to
this kind of genre not non-genre even
though there's some genres a little
crime in there i guess maybe a little
tiny bit of crime genre and this is the
night but it was nice to return to
something different yeah
do you ever wish that you had directed
all of the purge films yourself just to
say that you've directed them all or
or do you feel like it made the
franchise fresh for you again to see
what other filmmakers brought to it
it's a great question it's great because
i think about it too like oh should i
have stayed and just did all five and
but i don't think i had fatigue on
directing it definitely i was ready to
you know move on to this film and
but i also think that
because of the nature of what four and
five became uh
you know i was really being inspired by
the events of the country when four or
five were written even more than the
previous three
the dna of the socio-political landscape
seeped into the writing it was
inevitable because they are political
conceits the purges of political conceit
so everything that was starting to
happen in our country with the state of
discord and dissonance amongst
political parties and people seeped its
way in so and then hiring i think
diverse directors such as gerard and
elverado for the films i think actually
it it elevated them in a way that i
alone couldn't have done so sometimes i
think oh maybe i should have stayed on
and just had this you know these five
films that i wrote and directed how cool
but i think they actually made it better
than i would have done and
i think they brought out the
socio-political nature i might have
stayed more genre-based
oh
so yeah so and then maybe maybe it's
also giving me enough time away that i
might return for six we're actually
talking about that now so i think if i
didn't step away i would have
definitively walked i would be so purge
fatigued so
were there things that you learned from
learned about directing from making the
purge movies that you feel
you carried over to doing this film that
influenced this film in any way
yeah definitely the purge films are
they're incredibly and as jason knows
this so it's nothing against jason but
the the model is to do it cheaply but
make it look like a 50 million film
that's going to be released on july 4th
but you don't have 50 million you don't
have an earphone yeah
so
so it's very hard it really becomes
incredi and i know listen i'm not
complaining i love making films but even
me than more than me the crew by the
middle of these movies we're shooting
all nights usually a purge films all
night other than five which i wasn't
directing so i wasn't privy to the date
per shooting all nights
not much time and we're really fatigued
by it all so
so but you start to figure out how to
work within those parameters and
suddenly which actually sebastian i
jokingly always joke around like we're
almost
we've been beaten down to figure out how
to work for with no budgets
at this point you just start to figure
out well how can we make something look
great if you have the right people
on such a small budget and it was the
same thing on rocky 3 i knew i wanted to
make a
it has a magical feel so i knew it had
to have a certain look which that kind
of look is not easy to do on the time
allotted but since our dp anastas mikos
worked on purge four and also the
reshoots for purge three
uh and he was doing this tonight i think
we adopted a kind of
fast but non-compromising way to give it
a specific look that we learned from
doing if i hadn't done the purge
and learned all the tricks of the trade
on how to move quickly but not
compromised i don't think we would have
been able to because this knight was
even smaller than those films but it was
quite ambitious in scope so
so we learned a lot brought it to the
border to this is the night
how hard how hard was it to assemble
your young cast and to find actors who
could really embody this era and make it
feel real and authentic
when
they hadn't lived it
yeah great question so we waited we made
a deal sebastian jason and i when we uh
when jason said okay we're going but
let's make a deal if we can't find the
right boys let's not make it like we
have to feel good about excess the heart
and soul of the movie so it took a while
because i also had this specific thing i
they had to feel authentic to the 80s
like you said they also had to feel
authentic to new york staten island but
i also didn't want to play into the
cliches that i've seen so many times
with the heavy accents which is
definitely here but it's not always here
it's somewhat of a cliche it's overblown
in my opinion in movies and tv so it was
about finding someone that's believable
new york without being the cliche
and it was tough because we met great
actors whose accents were i felt a
little too thick and i wanted the movie
to have not just such a provincial feel
something a little more universal maybe
this could be anywhere yes i'm saying
staten island but maybe it could feel
like your hometown
so it was that really fine line but it
took it took about a year to get the
three boys but once we got them we felt
great we moved on to the
the bigger the bigger names in the cast
yeah because i i mean i love frank
grillo and yeah naomi watson this i i
think they're both so great in it and
they really are playing characters that
we're not really used to seeing from
them both of them i mean
frank obviously but even with naomi and
what was it that made you think of them
and did you need to do any convincing of
them to take on characters like this
luckily no that was great so i didn't
have to really do much of a sell
especially with both of them actually
frank i had gotten pushed from certain
people in the process to cast him as the
mob still which i didn't want to do i
was like that seems the easy choice
let's give
i know frank could do it frank's an
amazing actor everybody knows that but
he also could be quite vulnerable i
think we know him as this
hyper-masculine tough guy
guys like what's interesting is to see
that hyper-masculine guy kind of in the
subordinate role with this mobster who's
dominating because of financial reasons
and
and they're passed over with the love
triangle with the wife so i thought that
was interesting to put frank in this
vulnerable position and i thought he
roasted the occasion i knew he could do
we had done a mini series together that
i wrote in god 2005 where i saw him be
very vulnerable so i knew he had it it's
called kill point and he's wonderful in
it
so we had so frank was he was excited to
try something different too because he
thought he would be off with the mobster
when he got the script and then naomi
was just one of those i still can't
believe it i saw a list of names they
gave me a list and they were like well
who do you want my favorite actor on the
list was naomi i'm like oh she's my
favorite act she's the best but i i was
to me it was a ridiculous idea i'm like
well we have a couple of months let's
take one big shot let's take one insane
shot it's probably going to be a no
then we'll make a move to someone else
that's more realistic
and jason kind of knew naomi through i
think some somewhere back in the day
when he was working at miramax and he
said to the script and within a week and
a half i was sitting with her in
manhattan and
and we hit it off she loved the script
something touched her about it and
that was it and i was making a movie
with naomi watts he's the best actor
i've ever worked with so it was it was
amazing
yeah i think they were so great in it i
mean i i i was such a huge fan of
kingdom and frank's work on that show
yes yes and he does have such a huge
range in that show
but still different this was still
different the
relationship between this family was
still different than anything i've seen
him do yeah it was and i think he
enjoyed doing something different and uh
he had just come off doing uh the joe
carnahan film boss level so he was quite
muscular so we had to put him in a lot
of baggy clothes i don't know if you
noticed that so that was kind of but he
liked it he's like oh look i don't know
if people could see my big muscles so um
but it was definitely yeah he just
brought something different i still can
when i watch it today i'm like that's so
great to see that vulnerable face
especially at the end when you see him
kind of break
and acquiesce to his wife in that final
sequence i find it very touching to see
someone that tough
because that's the great thing about
frank why i keep casting frank's not
only is he a wonderful actor he actually
is authentically a tough guy you don't
want to mess with frank grillo that's a
very hard thing to find he's not acting
tough so
that's a great thing very rare we used
to get that back in the day with lee
marvin and charles bronson it's it's
kind of rare now but i think we get it
with frank that's why people love him
i i know that you have written the next
bird film and that
the plan is to bring frank back his
character back
where did
writing this purge start for you was it
knowing that you wanted to bring him
back and then you developed an idea
around that or did you come up with an
idea and think okay he could fit into
this that's the one yeah yeah it was
definitely i was i was done again i said
this before i know people say oh
demonically you're a liar but i was
truly done like i mean that i was like
five it's the end of america at the end
of five i felt like that was a cool way
to kind of end maybe with a little hope
that people will fight back but it was
kind of not to give away the ending of
fervor purge but it was kind of the end
of the america as we knew it as america
as we knew it
so i was finished and then i around i
guess it was around january with all the
craziness happening in washington on
january 6th i woke up a couple of weeks
later and i had this idea i couldn't
believe it i was actually shocked i'm
like oh i have an idea i think it's and
i'm like oh maybe it's not good though i
was kind of hoping it wasn't good
because i was done i was finished the
purge and uh i pictured the sebastian le
mercier my producing partner and he
loved it he was mad at me too he's like
oh god damn it to monaco come on you're
bringing us right back in just when we
thought we were out so we pictured the
jason he loved it peter kramer at the
studio loved it so
i went off i wrote it and uh it seems
everybody's happy with the script but
we're not green
oh and then so let's get back to your
question christina yeah so it was the
concept first of this kind of new
america that had been not to give away
too much but it was a new face of
america broken down towards very
strong tribal lines that we enter into
10 years after the forever purge
so it's been remapped in a way and then
but it was as soon as i came up with the
lead character it was just it was frank
so it was like i had the the world
and then i was like oh this is where
where's leo barnes now in this world and
that then it all just naturally fit into
place because
frank and i always said if we were gonna
do a sixth one let's do it together it
should be fun yeah i mean that that is
the character that's always sort of felt
like he hasn't fully had the ending yes
exactly we need to end so i think it's i
think it's a strong ending so we'll see
if if the if the studio wants it if the
audience wants it i think uh i think
we'll know soon hopefully we haven't
heard yet so
yeah i mean having written another purge
film now do you have more of a sense of
the end of the purge now or do you have
less of a sense of the end like do you
have another idea
no no no no i do not i'm going to say it
again no way no but i i don't i do but
it's weird because sebastian now that in
a weird way it's we're calling this like
chapter two it's such a different now
landscape we're entering into that
i guess there could be more i'll
probably say once again this is
definitely definitively my last one but
i woke up i said that on five so now i
sound like an idiot just saying it so um
but i see this as my end i do think that
the conceit of the sixth one can lends
itself to being more
i just i always worry that i never want
the idea to become exploitative which it
could be
so i do worry about that i want to make
sure it's it's handled well so even if
i'm not writing and directing it i think
sebastian and i will always stay
stay in the orbit of the purge world to
make sure it doesn't veer into a strange
place
it's just been such an interesting
franchise to watch because the
directions it's taken between
you know the first movies and then doing
films like the first purge and and even
the forever purge and doing the tv show
where you explore different areas
it's just been such an interesting
franchise to watch because
it it sort of allowed you to tell
different stories in a way that a lot of
other franchises can't even if you
wanted to
yeah it's not bound we always said
what's good about it is we're not bound
i should say this would it's not good
you're not bound to a character coming
back we love leo so we want him to come
back but
it's actually more it's individual
stories the purge allows it to go beyond
just oh this character like a rock the
rocket franchise needs rocky i mean now
they have adonis that they can continue
with and creed but
so certain franchises are based on those
characters fast and furious you need the
vin diesel character uh so
this is not bound out we just need to
concede that conceit just allows us to
keep diving into the american landscape
and maybe beyond that at some point i've
always wanted to see the purge
you know i always say the the american
culture travels around the world i would
imagine in this dystopian version of
america in the world the purge would
start traveling potentially to other
countries as a conceit that maybe as it
they're selling in america works so
maybe eventually we'll see it go
overseas somewhere but yeah it lends
itself to new stories every day so
i know you've said that this is the
night it has is a very autobiographical
film in different ways for you
would you say that there's a piece of
you
or your own family and every character
is there one character that's entirely a
fictional invention
yeah i'd say someone
i'm i would say i'm anthony anthony's me
the love of film the love of the
experience the the age was dissimilar
when i saw the film so anthony and then
going to sweet 16 i didn't go on that
night but the movie kind of inspired me
to make a strong move on the girl i
loved at the time it didn't work out the
way it does for anthony so that's
changed but uh
but i'd say the dad is representative of
the the hyper masculine males that i
grew up with brothers uncles fathers of
friends my dad's luckily a very
open-minded liberal
thinking forward-thinking man a
wonderful loving man so not that frank's
not but he had more of a hyper
masculinity that my dad was just more of
an open-minded guy
the christian character people asked me
about the most that's based without
obviously giving away a name on someone
i grew up with who struggled with their
sexual identity in 1982 staten island
which was what now looking back upon it
i keep using the warhawk damascus but
the hyper masculine society to be
dealing with that issue
at that time here
it was just profoundly difficult not i'm
saying it's not difficult in other
places but here i uh and even when he
came out to me he would say that how can
i ever tell anyone who i am and i didn't
even know i was very confused at that
age too so when i conceived of and he
always this person i knew and knew very
well still know
he found solace in movies tv and books
as his wakes he has nothing else there
was no other playstation there was no
internet there was no way to find out
who he was and people like him so he was
really locked off on this end of the the
island
and even manhattan at that time seemed a
hundred miles it seemed a million miles
away even though it's so close but when
we were young it seemed very far so
the idea that he always sought solace
and found uh
something in art books tv movies
whatever it was when i told him about
this storyline he loved that i was
applying his
his uh blooming and coming out with who
he was later in life took him years to
do that he loved that i was putting in
the context of film he thought that was
very interesting he took that's what
happened in a way with him film just was
something that he found great solution
yeah i thought that was such an
interesting character exploration
because i mean it's just the time period
there weren't even
people didn't even have words for things
that they have words for now so that's
why we said exactly they didn't there
was no labels there was no names of who
am i what am i now there's words there's
ways to identify okay and that that's a
great thing back then it was nothing and
he was quite he was very isolated even i
my response
for um
to him i think wasn't probably proper i
i was trying to be supportive but i was
very confused too because i had 1982
staten island this was unheard of uh
so yeah so it was uh it was
it was just a time really i think put
him in a box that he did not know how to
get out of and that's what i wanted to
portray here and it's a magical evening
so the events that christian goes
through
on this night are obviously compressed
in time in a way that would have taken
him years in real life he's dealing with
it in one magical evening so yeah but
that's that's the nature of the film i
guess yeah
when it comes to this film what are you
most proud of having accomplished with
it
i guess it's way too it's a great
question for things i watched it for the
first time i went to the theater to the
angelica to watch it with friends and
family the other night and
and it felt like my childhood that's
what i finally said i was i had the
distance enough to because you get so
caught up in these things they become an
obsession to the point of am i really
seeing my film the way it should be
seems i'm so close to it so it's so hard
to see your film like right even though
you watch it twice a week you're editing
it you're watching it every day but i
would always scream twice a week just to
get the overall feel
and then finally distance allowed me to
really watch it and i was sitting there
going oh it feels like when i it feels
like 1982 staten island and that that i
felt great about i left there feeling
kind of euphoric like wow that felt like
me and the guys running from the bullies
in the neighborhood for whatever reason
it was or kissing my first girl a
legends bar where we actually shot that
scene so it really captured that the
music and the feeling and i think it
captured for me
that what i feel
the theater experience can be this
magical place i know it's done in this
operatic very poetic way in the
screening of rocky but
i've had experiences similar during
rocky and other movies that felt as
magical so i think i think i got that
scene right for myself i can't say for
others but so i felt i felt proud of
those two things
yeah it's just it's such a fun movie to
watch it's fun and it's sweet and it
makes you feel good and it feels so
funny to see those things from the guy
who created the purge
i know i purge the purge i make people
feel good not horrible
i was gonna say but you deserve the
descriptions i mean the movie does it is
very it's it just i was surprised at
what a smile it put on my face because
it does give you
it gives you this feeling of nostalgia
in so many different ways
that's great i just i really want
i enjoyed that so much great thank you
it means a lot honestly yeah it was a
fun one to make and i just hope people
so i think we need i need we need to
feel good right now too i think it's
something that i tell people like you
want to feel it makes you feel good
which usually i can't say that for a
purge film so you can leave that with a
smile on your face so i hope people i
hope people get to see it now yeah
well before we wrap up then is there is
there another script aside from the
purge or an idea that's brewing that's
very different that you want to try to
take a stab at next well yeah the next
one which i'm doing right rewrite right
now on is um i don't know if i told you
about this last time we spoke it i hope
it's the next one to go it looks like it
could be is uh it's it's horror i'd say
it's definitely it's actually more
horror i would say than the purge of a
true horror fans i'd say it's more
horror genre it's i would say it's
psychological horror it's a paranoid
thriller horror but it's with uh pete
davidson's gonna look like he's gonna
star pete's attached uh who's a friend
of mine lives up the street here in
staten island and yeah we're hoping to
shoot in the new year where we just
finished drafts we've shown some people
there's interest so
with pete i think it's a great role for
pete it's a very serious role and that
looks like it'll be next i have a couple
other things brewing but nothing that
seems like the closest one to happening
with
pete i mean he's somebody that we've
seen a bit of acting from but we haven't
seen a ton of projects from him what
have you seen in him that
makes you think he's rightful
i saw when i saw him in
uh big time adolescence first and i've
known pete pete's been a purge fan we
got introduced with staten island guy so
we got introduced from a local
restaurant tour who's a friend said you
guys would hit it off and we met one
night at the bar the restaurant we got
to know he was a big purge guy
we actually started writing a script
together so i got to know him as a human
as a human being as a person first
before just an actor and uh
he's a great guy and then i had started
seeing his work and i'd seen him on
sunday live obviously like everybody
else and then big time adolescence
really blew me away i was like wow this
is an interesting character it's not
pete it's not that guy i know at all
pizza good like that character is a
little aloof he's a little always jokey
he's a little smart ass
pete's got that but pete's got a whole
other dimension and then i saw
a lot of that in king of staten island
and that blew me away i thought that he
had amazing a moment especially when
he's alone in that movie in my movies in
the home that's the one we might do
together he's alone quite a lot um and
those two i guess those two seeing them
back to back big time
then
king of staten island was like oh
there's something here that i think pete
feels right he read it he felt good too
and uh yeah so that's it so i hope that
makes sense i think so i think it's
wonderful
well i appreciate you talking to me
again no christina thank you so much i
love talking so anytime we talk about
other things
thank you so much